hey guys I'm just McDonald eat into the
26th of februari and you're watching
that show on that website hosted by that
australian chick thanks for that my
promise is my first and only Xbox one
story for the day Daisy's Dean horses
exciting things are coming to the
console naturally with a lead like that
he followed it up by saying that he cut
sharing details but he told Eurogamer
that in his meetings with Microsoft
there were things that came up which
made him say wow that's interesting why
don't you tell people that who also had
serious discussions with Sony about
releasing a closed-off version of daisy
though he suggested that it's probably
almost a year off getting the market he
said that the full PC version of the
game is expected to launch sometime in
the spring or summer of 2015 on top of
all that this week hall also confirmed
that he'll be leaving the dayz
development team and going back to New
Zealand because sheep in Lord of the
Rings are better than zombies let me
know what you reckon the xbox one secret
weapon is in the comments Rockstar I've
got themselves into hot water again
today by pissing off yet another rich
chick from Hollywood it's pretty much
the same story as last time too it seems
like GTA 5 may have gotten a little too
close to real life as they reinterpret
the lives that the Hollywood elite
because now former Mob Wives star Karen
Gravano was 14 million dollars as a
result of Rockstar allegedly copying her
image and life story a lawyer is arguing
that the character Antonia bertino is
based on her and she wasn't compensated
or credited for the role in a hilarious
example of what GTA 5 has certainly
strongly alluded to in the game and
tanya is told by her father that she
isn't allowed to start in a fictional
show called wise [ __ ] let me know if
you reckon rock stars in the wrong here
or nut and why or why not and from last
three of the day some sad news as got a
war dev Sony Santa Monica studio gets
hit with the massive layoffs Sony
confirmed the job cuts but hasn't
commented on the speculation over
whether this has resulted in the council
of an in-development ps4 game sony and
said the reason for the job losses is as
a result of a cycle of resource
realignment against priority growth
areas so basically your standard PR and
marketing speak you can let me know the
thoughts on any of today's stories in
the comments down below or you can do so
on my Twitter where I'm at just McDonald
oh and also titanfall will only be
taking up 20 gigabytes of your xbox one
hard drive space not 40 so yay for that
those are all the things that I have to
tell you today but be sure to join me
again same time tomorrow for a whole
bunch more news I'll see you later